>> I'm Jennifer Cutting,
folklife specialist
at the American Folklife Center
at the Library of Congress.
It's September 20, 2018 and
we're here interviewing some
of our artists from tonight's
Homegrown Series Archive
Challenge Sampler Concert that's
taking place tonight at 7:30
in the Coolidge Auditorium.
And we have with us the group
that's going to be first
up in the concert, the
Ship's Company Chanteymen.
And we only have two
of the Chanteymen,
we'll talk about
the others later
but with us right now
is the business manager
of Ship's Company
Chanteymen, Myron Peterson.
We also have folklife
specialist and writer/editor
from the American Folklife
Center, Steve Winick,
who's going to guest
tonight with Ship's Company.
So welcome.
>> Thank you.
>> And I guess the first
question I had for you Myron,
is I understand that Ship's
Company Chanteymen is part
of a larger organization
called Ship's Company,
and I was wondering if you could
tell us what the relationship is
between Ship's Company
Chanteymen and Ship's Company,
the larger organization.
And how Ship's Company
Chanteymen came to be.
>> Ship's Company Incorporated
is a non-profit organization,
incorporate in the
state of Maryland,
and we do historic presentations
and, centered around the life
of the sailor from
the early wars period,
the American Revolution,
predominantly now the War
of 1812, and also for
the American Civil War.
And this started about 35
years ago on, doing programs
on the Constellation in
Baltimore, and at that time,
the ship was considered
the original 1797 frigate.
We know now that that is
not the case, it's a rebuild
from the 1850's, and so the
ship did see service during the
American Civil War
so the group decided
to expand out into Civil War.
And for a while that almost
become the primary focus
but there were a number of us
who really enjoyed
the early wars period,
and as the bicentennial of
the War of 1812 approached,
we got a much better research
and understanding of the navy
of the War of 1812, building
on what it was during
the American Revolution,
during the Quasi-War with France
during the first Tripolitan War.
>> Mm hmm.
>> In between shows
on Constellation
and in the early days when we
were still doing Quasi-War,
some of us would you
know, spend the time
between our doing gun drill,
which was the predominant show,
just singing to entertain
ourselves and it was to say hey,
we actually don't sound too bad
and so a small group
of that got together.
We shanghaied a few other
people from the folk community,
notably K.C. King who had been
a member of the Boarding Party.
>> Oh yes.
>> And formed the Ship's
Company Chanteymen in 1996.
So, and we started you know,
the usual, we'll do this for fun
and exposure, and now you know,
we do this for money,
we're mercenaries.
>> Okay, and what kind of
repertoire do you focus on?
>> We focus on nautical
songs, we like songs
with a relationship to sailing,
the sea, and they can be modern
so we can go into steam and
diesel as well, we don't mind.
But that, we like
that relationship
between the sailors
and the song.
Now some of it is, a tavern
song from the early periods,
you'll see that occasionally
where we're singing.
What was popular because sea
chanteys as we understand it,
mostly evolved in the later
part of the 19th century.
There are very few chanteys
from the very early periods.
A chantey is used to
coordinate work onboard ship,
navy ships especially;
they didn't like them,
because the first command
in the navy is silence.
So you've got to be able to hear
commands and they had man power.
The merchant ships
on the other hand,
didn't have the man power
you know, a lot of people,
so they had to coordinate
the work more
and that's the chanteyman and --
>> Oh, I see.
Now I understand that
you were in the navy
for over 20 years yourself.
>> That's correct.
>> As, what was your position?
>> I was a Russian interpreter
for the navy, I was trained
by the navy, and attend the
rank of chief petty officer.
I retired in 1996 so just before
the Chanteymen started so,
a little more free with my time.
Before that I was deploying
at the will of the navy,
on board various ships,
a lot of submarines.
>> I was wondering was music
part of your daily life
in any way while
you were in the nav?
>> Not particularly
although on one
or two trips there would be
people who would get together
and you know, somebody would
have a guitar, and they'd sing
and you know, it was a
way to pass the time,
especially when you're working,
in my case, working twelve hours
with twelve hours off every
day, but there's nothing to do.
>> Yeah.
>> So singing, like I
said, but it was very rare.
Most everybody, the music
involved, later especially,
of a set of headsets and a tape.
>> Yeah. Gotcha.
Well, moving over the Steve
now, I know that you did most
of the research for tonight's
performance, which is convenient
because you work in the
American Folklife Center.
Tell me a little about
the collections you used
and why you chose the
songs that you did.
>> Alright I'll say, first off,
that I am the writer and editor
in the American Folklife Center
here at the Library of Congress,
but I'm also a long-time member
of Ship's Company Chanteymen.
I've been kind of on the
inactive list for a while
so I haven't been doing a
lot of gigs with the group,
but I have been a
member of the group
for over 10 years now I guess.
And because of that,
when this idea came
up to have the Chanteymen
in the Archive Challenge,
it sort of made sense
because I was kind
of the inside guy, right?
I already worked here and
I knew the collections
so the question was, what would
be the best songs for us to do.
Two of them come from the James
Madison Carpenter collection
and that's partly because that
collection has been getting more
attention lately because
it's been digitized
by The American Folklife
Center, and placed online
at the Ralph Vaughan Williams
Memorial Library in England,
which is part of the English
Folk Dance and Song Society,
and so during that process
of them putting it online
and us getting them the
digital files, we were all kind
of working with the
collection somewhat.
And so I became familiar with
some of the pieces in there
and they were really
interesting pieces.
Carpenter was an American
who collected both in the US
and in Britain in the late '20s
and early '30s, which is kind
of an underrepresented time
in folklore collecting.
And the two songs that I chose,
one is a very interesting
version of Blow the Man Down,
which is a well-known sea
chantey that everyone does
in the sea chantey scene
but it's a completely
different version
than anyone else ever does.
Because Carpenter was very
interested in sea chanteys
and in fact wrote his doctoral
dissertation on nautical songs,
but his professor that he
was writing this doctoral
dissertation for, was
George Lyman Kittredge
who was the student of
Francis James Child,
who was the preeminent ballad
scholar of the 19th century
after whom we even have a
category of ballads names,
so we all talk about the Child
ballads in folklore circles.
And so what Carpenter discovered
was that one of these versions
of Blow the Man Down,
has lyrics of the verses
that are a Child ballad, a Child
ballad was actually adapted
into a version of
Blow the Man Down.
And this interested him so much,
he collected it three
times actually;
twice in New York
and once in Wales.
And so that was one
that I thought stood
out from the collection
for all those reasons.
Partly because everyone would
be somewhat familiar with it,
but not familiar at
all with this version.
>> And you have blended verses
from different field recordings
to create the version that
you're going to perform tonight.
>> Yes, in fact, this was
early in Carpenter's career
and he mostly collected this
one in writing as opposed
to on cylinders and so
we have written text
and transcriptions of it.
But yeah--
>> And it looks like they
were all collected in 1928.
>> Yes, interestingly enough.
And that kind of shows you
that it might have been a sort
of micro-era in that chantey's
life when this version existed
and then kind of faded quickly.
These three men, certainly
two of them knew each other,
because they were both retired.
>> Because they were both
at Sailor's Snug Harbor.
>> Exactly, which is a sailors'
rest home in Staten Island
in New York, and
it's quite possible
that they knew the
third guy as well
because these crews were
often international.
>> And the other guy
was Richard Warner
from Cardiff, in South Wales.
>> Cardiff in South
Wales, right.
So yeah, I combined some
verses from all of them,
primarily I'm doing a
version that he recorded
from Dennis O'Connor's in
Sailor's Snug Harbor but I put
in a couple of verses
from others.
>> Okay, we've got three more
songs to cover in 5 minutes,
so yeah, let's go ahead and talk
about On Board the [inaudible],
the other song from the
Carpenter collection.
>> Yeah, that's an interesting
one too, which Carpenter,
as I said, he wrote his
dissertation on sea music and so
when we were going
through his collection,
there were some items
that we have notebooks
with tunes written down,
but we don't have the
words for those tunes.
And it turns out that
this is one of those,
so I found the tune
in his collection,
but then when looking at
his doctoral dissertation,
I found that the
words are in there.
So we were able to
match those up together.
And I was actually alerted to
this by our friend Bob Walser,
who's been working with
the collection quite a bit,
and it appealed to me because
it's a song that tells the story
of a fishing trip
from Massachusetts
up to Atlantic Canada
and I've heard the tune
up in Atlantic Canada.
It's still an oral tradition
but not with these words.
So I thought that was an
interesting piece as well
and we put that one together.
>> So this is a great reunion.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> The reunion of the
tune and the words.
Now let's jump to William
Derflinger's [phonetic]
collection of Patrick Taylor.
From that collection,
you chose Reuben Ranzo.
>> Yeah and that's
only because I mean,
Taylor was an incredible
singer and chantey man
but also a great story teller.
And he gave these incredible
introductions for some
of his songs including
Reuben Ranzo,
so we decided we'd play a
piece of his introduction--
>> Using that tonight.
>> Using so we'll hear Taylor's
voice introducing the song
and then Myron's actually
going to sing that one.
But it's another very
well-known sea chantey which is
about a tailor who goes to sea.
Sailors often made fun
of tailors and a lot
of people did in those days.
Tailors had the kind
of stereotypical
repetition of being wimps.
That's sort of the joke
that is always being told
about tailors in that era.
>> And over to Jolly
Roving Tar from the Anne
and Frank Warner collection.
>> So that is a song again,
that all nautical groups know.
It's very well-known in this
community but what nobody knows,
or very few people know, is
that everybody knows that song
because of a single field
recording that's in our archive.
And that was a recording
made by Anne and Frank Warner
of Lena Born Fish [phonetic],
in East Jaffrey New
Hampshire in 1940.
>> Nineteen-forty, mm hmm.
>> So when I learned that that
was the case and I learned
that actually from
Jeff and Garrett Warner
who were here just a few
weeks ago, I thought wow,
that would be a great fourth
song to do in our set and we put
that one together as well.
>> And did Ship's Company
already sing a version
of Jolly Roving Tar?
>> Yes, that's one that's
in our general repertoire.
>> In your repertoire.
>> Yeah.
>> And the interesting
thing being
that you probably learned it
from someone who learned it
from someone else,
who learned it
from the Lena Born Fish
the field recording.
>> Yes, so the way
that worked was
that the Warner's were good
friends with the Lomax's
and they played this field
recording for the Lomax's
who put it in one of their
books and so a transcription
of this was released in a book
and so it was then learned
by a lot of people
in the folk revival.
But another thing that
none of those people knew,
the Lomax's didn't know it,
the Warner's didn't know it,
and Lena Born Fish didn't
know it, she had learned it
from a retired whaling sailor.
But none of these people knew
that it was actually a
stage song that was written
by Ned Harrigan of
Harrigan and Hart fame.
But it wasn't written
with Hart, it was written
with his father-in-law,
a man named Dave Brahm.
And they wrote it for a play
called Old Lavender which was
on Broadway, and it was you
know, it became popular not only
with you know, everyday
popular culture,
but it became popular
with sailors.
And so it went to sea and was
then collected from sailors
by Lena Born Fish,
among other people.
And so it's a great story of one
of those kind of dramatic songs
about sailing life that
actually caught on with sailors.
And that wasn't uncommon.
>> And made its way
into the oral tradition.
>> Right. That wasn't uncommon,
that did happen quite a
bit in the tradition so.
>> Well, we're looking
forward to hearing all
of these four songs tonight
in the Archive Challenge
Sampler Concert
from the Homegrown
Concert Series
in the American Folklife Center
in the Coolidge Auditorium
tonight at 7:30.
Thank you gentlemen for being
with us for this interview.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.